welcome back to New rockstars I'm when
Evian laningham and after seeing miles
and Gwen's relationship further explored
and across the spiderverse I started
revisiting my favorite Miles Morales
Spider-Man comics looking back at his
stories however it turns out that Miles
Morales has dated several other Marvel
heroes besides Glenn and even has a
completely different girlfriend in the
current Miles Morales Spider-Man Vol 2
run so today I'm taking you through a
history of everyone Miles Morales has
dated in the comics you never know some
of these other baddies might end up in
the spider-verse the Sony verse or even
the MCU if you enjoy this video let me
know in the comments that I can break
down other Heroes romantic history and
future vids
in case you missed it new rock stars
isn't just one channel anymore it's
three earlier this year we launched the
Deep dive where I dig into the deeper
meaning behind everything you love and
our newest channel the break room is
where all of your nerdy friends are
gonna hang out online it's also the new
home for inside Marvel and all of our
reactions to the latest trailers TV
shows and movies we've got so many cool
videos planned so head on over and
subscribe and while you're at it don't
forget to subscribe to the new
Rockstar's main Channel and the Deep
dive starting off miles is romantic
history we've got an early crush on
Cassie Lang folks when miles battled the
Mind Control Giant Woman in Ultimate
Comics Spider-Man number 18. he admits
that he's embarrassed about finding a
girl of her stature still attractive
it's okay buddy lots of dudes out there
like giantesses ain't no shame in the
Tom lady game obviously this is just a
fleeting momentary crash but miles's
first real relationship is with another
young Avenger variant Kate Bishop miles
must have a thing for Haley Steinfeld
types I'm looking at you too Mt Hertz
1610's Catherine Bishop isn't Hawkeye in
training like she is in 616 or 199999
wait
yeah okay got that right she's actually
the daughter of hydra agents unbeknownst
to Miles and a fellow student at the
Brooklyn vision Academy Kate Bishop is
first seen crushing on miles from afar
in the ultimate comic Spider-Man issues
12 and 19. we missed the details to the
start of their relationship thanks to a
one-year time skip after Venom kills
miles's mother Rio but sometime during
this period miles and Kate start going
steady miles contemplates telling Kate
about his secret Spider-Man identity but
initially decides against it wanting to
keep her and her loved ones safe from
super villain harm this desire to share
his truth with her is exacerbated by a
rejection from his father after miles
Reveals His identity to Papa Jefferson
he's blamed for his mother's death
obviously this makes him even more
afraid to tell Kate his secret at the
end of the next issue however miles
decides to tell his girlfriend that he
is in fact Spider-Man terrified Kate
runs away from him and ends up confiding
in her sister who tells their father
Derek Bishop Bishop uses this
information to drug and kidnap miles and
when Kate tries to defend her father and
Hydra he dumps her ass after getting
burned by dating Kate miles goes through
an era of casual crushes one of these is
Marvel girl Earth's 616's teenage Jean
Gray an all-new X-Men number 31-36 Gene
and her fellow X-Men end up displaced
into the 1610 universe so Miles helps
Gene meet with her ultimate variant to
defeat Doctor Doom and return home both
Jean Grays can psychically sense that
miles is crushing hard on Marvel girl
and before she leaves his corner of the
Multiverse teen Jean kisses smile on the
cheek in all new ultimates number two
miles gets a big old smoocharoo from the
criminal leader of the serpent skulls
Diamondback AKA Rachel Layton no dating
here because Diamondback is a murderous
scumbag but she did confirm her crush on
Spidey by kissing in mid-battle in the
all-new all different Avengers annual
miles is Champions teammate Miss Marvel
starts beefing with a fanfic writer
named badmachine199 apparently
badmachine199 keeps publishing stories
about a love triangle between Champions
members Spider-Man Nova and Ms Marvel by
the end of the issue it turns out the
bad machine is none other than Miles
Morales who confesses that he dreams
about Ms Marvel flirting with him and
Miles isn't the only one who thinks that
this pair has chemistry this issue also
features another writer's fanfic about
his Marvel and spider mole going on a
date despite being a commonly shipped
pair this is the closest we get to True
Romance between the two breakout 2010s
characters a lot of people ask me how
I'm able to stay focused researching all
these videos and honestly it's this
one shot Energy Chews are a healthy and
convenient energy boosting supplement
candy for gamers athletes YouTube hosts
and everybody really they make energy
shoes and Focus Shoes the focus shoes
are my go-to but it just depends on what
you need each energy has 75 milligrams
of pure caffeine plus 600 milligrams of
additional nootropics to give you a
serious energy boost that works
immediately as you chew Focus choose now
available in limited edition new
Rockstar's theme packaging really help
me concentrate and give me a natural
boost of energy with BCD and E vitamins
plus zinc to help with immune system
support and the amino acid tyrosine both
energy choose and focus shoes are a
plant-based naturally sweetened and
designed to give you the energy and
focus you need without a bunch of
fillers and chemicals get started with
one shot energy today by going to one
shotenergy.com new rockstars for 10 off
your order next up we've got the girl
most of y'all are waiting for When Stacy
of Earth 65. adorably we see miles and
Gwen's relationship blossom in a
Spider-Man spider Gwen crossover titled
sitting in a tree that ran for six total
issues between the two comics series
these two end up bonding for some of the
same reasons that they do went into the
spider-verse and across the spider-verse
they have a ton of things in common as
Spider folk with secret identities and
an unmistakable attraction Maria Hill
sends miles to Earth 65 in search of his
father who in an attempt to protect
miles accepted a mission to intercept
technology that allows a person to
travel between realities not unlike the
wristbands from across the spider-verse
when he first arrives miles meets Gwen
fighting the ringer and learns that Gwen
gets her Spider Woman powers from
radioactive isotopes nicknamed power-ups
sold to her by the evil alternative
version of Matt Murdock like an across
the spider verse this Glenn's best
friend Peter Parker died the night of
their senior prom after turning himself
into a lizard to impress her
interestingly Milo gets a little
embarrassed when his crutches Collide
Miss Marvel meets Gwen for the first
time in spider Gwen number 17 and Kamala
gives Gwen the old don't you dare hurt
the sweet baby boy's heart speech when
miles and Gwen go Dimension hopping with
their multiversal watch they end up
discovering an alternate reality where
where they've been married for 20 years
although miles makes it back to Earth 65
Gwen lands in Earth 8 where she needs to
earn miles's future children Charlotte
and Max after miles finds his dad and
Gwen returns home they share a kiss but
Gwen ultimately tells him that she's not
in the right headspace for a boyfriend
right now and they decide to remain
friends at about this time miles gets
into an awkward position by his old new
ultimates team-mate Lana baumgarter Lana
AKA bombshell used to run with miles in
his early superheroing years and in
Spider-Man Vol 2 number 17 and 18 she's
hospitalized after a fight with
Hammerhead Spider-Man and his friend
classmate and X-Men gold balls bring
Hammerhead to Justice despite the fact
that gold balls was the one to defeat
him Lana develops a crush on miles after
seeing Spidey fight Hammerhead on the
news the fact that his name is gold
balls also probably had something to do
with it put a pin in this developing
love triangle for just a little bit
during the same period we meet Barbara
Rodriguez in Spider-Man 2 number one
miles is immediately submitting from the
moment he sees her and asks his buddy
Genki what the the new girl's deal is
genki's like bro WTF that's Barbara I
did a school project with her and we
literally all went to the movies that
one time but after Raz and his friend
for not noticing the cutest girl in
school he Clues him in telling miles
that Barbara is super nice cute and has
a voice like Alicia Keys Matchmaker
Genki gets Barbara and miles to start
talking about school and she even teases
miles about his frequent tendency to
sneak out of the dorms in the midst of
their conversation however a giant robot
head falls from the sky and it's
revealed in Issue Number Four that Miles
saved her from getting pancakes she
thanks him for saving her and semi
seriously asks him if he's a mutant or
an inhuman she lets him know that she
can sense he's hiding something and he
can trust her miles thinks her for
offering to talk about his secret life
but tells her he needs to think about it
he does however offer to take her to the
movies his pal Genki even recommends The
Perfect film for her Close Encounters
solid film Choice mad respect but
remember all gold balls when he finds
out that miles is dating Barbara he
starts telling him off in Lana's honor
miles is like it's cool dude I'm with
Babs I don't feel feelings for Lana
which leads gold balls to realize that
he might be crushing on Lana himself
this does cause some friction with
Barbara however because she overhears
miles talking to Genki about Lana and
worries he might be cheating on her but
their relationship gets back on stable
ground for a bit and the pair spend a
significant amount of time dating they
watch her little cousin together
occasionally and Miles supports her
blossoming music career she's sort of
the MJ to his Pete But ultimately
Barbara ends up dumping Miles because he
can't be honest with her about his
Secrets he never tells her about his
life as Spider-Man despite the fact that
she's clearly pieced it together herself
by this point even though this break is
a bit awkward for their friend group
Barbara still supports Smiles by
protecting his identity a handful of
times after they break up she ends up
exploring her feelings for Genki who's
clearly always been keyed into what
makes her special unfortunately this
pairing doesn't last nearly as long and
the two supporting characters decide
they should focus on schoolwork if
Barbara is miles is MJ next we've got
his black cat fresh off of his breakup
with Barbara we meet Tiana Tunes AKA
starling AKA vulture's granddaughter the
two first met in Miles Morales
Spider-Man Vol 1 issue number five when
they run into each other hunting down
Tombstone although Spider-Man is eager
to work with her he also feels that
Sterling's fighting style is a little
too rough like yeah she's super hot and
Kick-Ass and Powerful but she also tried
to drop Tombstone from the sky instead
of bringing him to Justice it's a little
too murdery for miles but baby girl was
trained by Adrian tombs so it's not like
she's the type to go easy on her
opponents but despite her
semi-off-putting violent streak when it
comes to criminals she's basically
miles's dream girl he Reveals His
identity to Tiana in issue number 22
after defeating Frost pharaoh and they
finally kiss while this relationship is
being explored the writers thought it
would be nice to give us some closure on
another [__] in issue 24 miles catches
up with his friend Kamala Khan aka Miss
Marvel although awkward Crush Vibes are
in the air the two talk about their
failed relationships over ice cream and
decide that friendship is much too
important to ruin with romance Tiana and
Miles meet on a rooftop to make out and
issue number 30 and issue number 42
shows us the two of them actually dating
in addition to fighting crime together
Starling tells Spidey that she doesn't
have a ton of rules when it comes to
relationships but if he wants to be with
her he needs to open up about his
feelings unfortunately when Miles
Morales Spider-Man Vol 2 came around the
first couple issues showed miles pulling
away from Tiana when she confronts him
about ghosting her he gives the classic
superhero excuse he's afraid that
everyone he loves will eventually get
hurt and that his double life as miles
and Spider-Man is Weighing on him
Tiana's like LOL okay that's what
literally every hero says and it's not
an excuse to be a dick so Miles promises
to catch up with her later to talk
things out but oh no miles is attacked
by scorpion and a mysterious robot
kidnaps Tiana the woman operating the
robot is Tech genius Rene Rashad aka the
rabble whose whole entire villain thing
is resenting Miles Morales it turns out
that she was up for the same lottery for
a spot of Brooklyn Visions Academy but
miles is number 42 was called instead of
hers after she and Miles fight both are
wounded but the rabble manages to
capture Genki and threaten miles's
entire family miles nearly dies trying
to save his family girlfriend and best
friend from his jealous as hell Nemesis
but Rasheed manages to slink back to her
headquarters where she and Scorpion plan
their next attack T does pop up again in
spider-verse unlimited Infinity Comics
volume 1 issue number 48 and we see
these two cuties kiss at the top of the
Brooklyn Bridge before miles is brain
paged by Madame wet but the last time we
see her in the comics is still in volume
2 of Miles Morales Spider-Man where it's
confirmed in issue number six that
things are finally back to normal and
startling in Spider-Man's relationship
Tiana is miles's most recent girlfriend
in the comics and arguably one of his
more serious ones but with Miles Morales
Spider-Man Vol 2 only 6 issues deep so
far we're gonna have to see how the rest
of this run plays out in the future
these are all of Miles Morales love
interest from the comic so far but I
want to know which ones you think might
pop up on the big screen next if the MCU
does decide to make a live-action
version of Miles Morales I could
definitely see them fleshing out his
relationship with Kamal or even
introducing him to Giant Cassie Lang
follow me on Instagram and Twitter
whitneypuppy follow me Rockstar
subscribe to new Rockstar's more
analysis of everything you love and
thanks for watching bye
[Music]
foreign